で タンキンマンニャシ
あなたはどのように思いますか？アーナンダよ
カンアッタワサンサンパッサマーナ
カンアッタワサンというのは
まあ何かこの目的というか
何かまぁ 何のためというね
まぁいわゆる目的のことですね
どのようにあのことを考えて利益を考えてサンパッサマーナ
まぁそれ考えることですね
アラハティサーヴァコサッターランアヌバンディトゥン
サッターランっていうのは師匠のことで
先生のことで アヌバンディトゥンというのは
まあ追っていくと いわゆるまあ先生の後ろから
まぁ一応歩くということで
アヌバンディトゥンまぁ
まぁ従って行くっていうことですね
だからまぁ カンアッタワサンサンパッサマーナどんな
何のためにどんな目的を考えて
師匠をサーヴァコ 弟子が
あの 負うべきでしょうかと
アーナンダよ このことをどう思いますか？つまり
弟子はたとえ拒絶されても
どのような道理を見て師に従うべきかということです
うんうん というところですね
順番かなり変わりますから
アーナンダよ この 何だったっけ
このことをどう思いますかと
そのことをどう思いますかと
つまり弟子はたとえ拒絶されて- それはこのタンキンマンニャシという意味なんですね
で それからキンアッタワサンサンパッサマーナというの訳は
うーんと 出てないな どのような道理を見て師に従うべきかというね
ということです  それで最後にアピパヌッジャマーナ
パーリ語で最後に入れてアピパヌッジャマーナ
追い出されてもというね
いや先生 それは弟子はたとえ拒絶されてもというところに感じるわけ
うん だから弟子を まぁ師に追い出されて
拒絶されて まぁ追い出されても
やっぱりそれでもその師を追っかけて行った方がいい場合は
どの場合はそのことをやってもよろしいかと
まあまあ あんまりうーんと説明しない方がいいということですけど
まああの まあこの場合はこの師弟関係というものを説明しているんですね
まあまあ 経典の前のところは
まあ一応私にできる限りは説明しましたけど
まあいろいろ間違いあったかもしれませんし
それはまあ裏で批判すればよろしいし
前で説尊 説尊が出さないで
で あいつは仏教はわからない
間違ってるんだと まあ一応まあ知識的な勉強の場合は
何か気にかかったこと
引っかかったことっていうのはその場で聞くことですけどね
まあそれはそれで まあ次に
ですから前のことを全然もう振り返しても省略も何もしません
で 勝手にしてってくださいっていうことで
あの次にあの 師弟関係って何なのかっていうところで
まあいろいろ師弟関係っていうのはこの世の中でありまして
インドの場合は まあ一応日本と違ってね
やっぱり師弟関係っていうのはちょっと
あの かなり厳密なもんなんですね
で 弟子についちゃって
一応勉強してみるし まあだからって他の先生のところに行くこともできるし
で だからものすごく自由な世界でいる人々にとっては
こんな師弟関係っていうのは何なのかということがわからないかもしれませんしね
で こちらで言ってるのは弟子
一応先生が追い出すんですね
あんたはもう出て行けと
もうあんたはもう弟子として認めたくないと
それで認めたくないと追い出されても追い出されても頑張って頑張って先生のところに行った方がいいというところなんですけど
だからといって それで認めるわけにいきません
どんなような何を認めて
そうやってこの先生にしがみつくんでしょうかというところで
このどのような先生で
どのような弟子であるべきかという
そこら辺は説明しようとしているんですね
そこでアナンダ尊者はバガワバガワンモーラカーノーバンテダーマバガワーネッティカー
バガワンパティサラナーサードゥーアタバンテバガワンタンイエバパティバートゥエータッサバーティタッサアットバガヴァートースッアービククダーレスサンティーティ
アナンダ尊者が別にそれわからないし
わからないだけではなくて
お釈迦様は最初に質問を出したっていうことは
そこら辺をお釈迦様は説明したがっているんですよ
ですから 昔の弟子たちはそれはすごく理解してて
すぐ質問するんですね
そこら辺 説明 説明しようとしているんだと
先生は だったら先生に説明しやすくするために質問しようではないかという悪い性格があったんですね
今と違って それでアナンダ尊者が法というのはバガワバガワンモーラカ
お釈迦様は根源であると
バガワンネッティカー
法というのはお釈迦様が導いてリーダーになって
リーダーはお釈迦様でバガワです
バガワンパティサラナ
この真理はお釈迦様に頼っているんだと
拠り所にしてるんだと
ですから サードゥーアタバンテバガワンタンイエバパティバートゥ
ですから その答えはお釈迦様に思い出すように
お釈迦様はどのようにこの質問にお考えになっているんでしょうかと
その方が説明した方がサードゥーよろしいんではないかと
だから 私の意見 あの人の意見とかね
師弟関係についてね いろいろ意見言うよりは
法はお釈迦様が根源であって
お釈迦様に頼っていて
お釈迦様はリーダーであって
ですからお釈迦様が教えた方がよろしいんじゃないかなというふうに
パティバートゥエータッサバーティタッサバーシタッサアット
今おっしゃった言葉の意味はお釈迦様の理解の通りによろしいと
バガヴァートースットは釈尊から聞いて
ビククダーレスサンティーティ比丘たちは理解するだろう
ネクワアナンダラハティサーワコサッチャーランアヌバンディトゥンヤティダンスッタンゲイヤンウェッヤーカラナッサヘトゥ
タンキッサヘトゥディーガラタッサヒウォアナンダダッマ
スッターダターワジャサーパリチッターマナサーアヌペッティターディッティアーサッパティヴィッダ
ヤー
チャコーヤン・アーナンダ・カタービ・サッレーキッター・チェトー・ヴィヴァラナ・サッバーヤー・エーカンタ・ニンビダーヤ・ヴィラーガーヤ・ニローダーヤ・ウパ
サーマーヤ・アビニャーヤ・サンボーダーヤ・ニッバーナーヤ・サンワッタ・ヴィセイヤティーダン・アッピッチキャター・サントゥッティカーター・パヴィヴェーカ
カーター・アサンサッガカーター・ヴィリーアランバカーター・シーラカーター・サマーディカーター・パンニャーカーター・ヴィムッティカーター・ヴィムッティ・
ニャーナ・ダッサンカーター・エーヴァルーピーヤー・コー・アーナンダ・カターヤ・ヘトゥ・アラハティ・サーヴァコー・サッターラン・アヌバンディトゥン・アピパユッジャマーノ
そこでこの まあなんで先生のところに行くかというと
あの それ先生からいろいろ勉強してもらうためなんですね
そこでお釈迦様の場合はお釈迦様を先生にして
お釈迦様のところに弟子入
弟子入りする場合も お釈迦様の話を
まあ聞きたいという気持ちはあるんですね
そこで他のところでも
お釈迦様の説法するときは
お釈迦様はこの九つの方法で説法しているんだから
説法する方法が まあ経典
今経典にもなってますよ
九つあるんだと それはスッタン・ゲーヤン・ウェイヤーカラナン
えーと ジャータカン どこでしたっけ？スッタン・ゲーヤン・ウェイヤーカラナン
それしか書いてないな
とにかくこの同じ経典
どこかに出てくるはずなんです
全部リスト まあスッタン・ゲーヤン・ウェイヤーカラナン
えーと ジャータカン アッブタダンマン
ウダランなんとかなんとか
まあ九つの法があるんだと
それで注釈書では それはこのお釈迦様がおっしゃった教えは全部その九つに分け分けられ
分けられると では思っているし
まあ大乗経典になってくると
時代になってくると九つは十二になっていくんですね
で この十二のカテゴリーの法があるんだと
教えがあるんだというね
で まあどちらにしたっても
その九つって何なのかっていうのは
北伝も南伝もあまりわかっていなかったみたいんですね
ですから まあとにかく
まあスッタっていうのはスートランタという経典みたいなことで
この前説明しましたから
それを思い出してみてください
九つの一つ一つ説明しました
まあゲーヤっていうのは
このゲーとサンとプロス
両方混ぜてあるもので
あの 日本語で何と言いますかね
それは 散文と何とか文なんですね
韻文と散文 両方あって
喋る場合はゲーヤというし
ウェイヤーカラナっていうのは
この質問形式で これは何なのか
その場合はこれこれやと
こういう場合は何なのかと
これはこういうことだという風に
このダイアログ質問形式で喋ることがウェイヤーカラナ
それでガータンというのは
ただ歌で散文だけで喋るというね
まあ全部一つ歌を作歌
詩を作って 詩でずっと説法するというのがガータン
ウダーナっていうのは何かに感動して
何かね まあその感動の表現ですね
まあイティヴッタカンという方法がありまして
イティヴッタカンというのは
何かに引用して で この間
まあなんとかなんとか言ったら
こういうことを言ったんではないかと
それはどういう意味でしょうかとかね
そういう風に何かに引用してすること
話すことなんですね ですから
お釈迦さんもいろんなことに引用して喋った可能性はあるし
で 昔の人々はこんなこと言ったんではないかとかね
それから自分自身でもおっしゃったことに
また二番目に私はなんとかなんとか
場所でこういうふうなことを言いましたよと
ということ 自分のことに引用して
それはどういう意味でしょうかという風に
まあそうやって そういう形式で喋るんですね
うん それからアッブタダンマンという話し方がありまして
普通の人々はびっくりする
なんか理解できない なるほど
不思議だなという そういうふうなこの感覚を不思議と
そういうような感覚を気持ちを引き起こしながら喋る方法っていうのはブッダダマっていうことで
それからウェーダンランということがありまして
ウェーダンランって何なのか誰もわかってないみたいんですけど
あの それはまあアビダンマ大になってくるとワイプッリヤになってきて
それはおそらく大乗では中論やらクーロンも喋ることやと言ってますけどね
それはまあいい加減なことなんですけど
ワイプッリヤっていうのはおそらくこのすごいこのソクラテスの話みたいな感じで
ものすごいこの淡々と厳密に論理的な哲学的なことを喋ると
その場合は聞く相手はどんな人でもいいわけじゃなくてね
ちゃんと相手もすごく喜んで
ものすごいこの知識の言葉淡々と喋ると
いわゆる哲学ソクラテスの話を聞いたとかね
という風な驚きますね
話を聞いて すごい頭ではなんかすごいいいことを教えてくれたとかね
そういうふうなこの知識的な話がウェーダンランということになって
それで全部九つなんですよ
そういう教え方があるんです
説法の仕方があるんです
ここでお釈迦様が言うのは
このスッタゲイヤレイヤーからの御恩のために弟子入りしてはいけませんと
いわゆるお釈迦様の話を喜ぶために
ただ 愛想の話も聞いていられますよ
聞いてると楽しいですよとかね
そういう歌あるは エピソードあるは
詩はあるは もうすごい感動的な話もあるとかね
だからもう行って色々側にいて
ずっと話もそっちを聞いてみましょうという
そこはもうもうそうやんなくそんな感じで弟子入りするなよという
まあまあ一応まあまあこちらのポイントは全く説明しなくても
ポイントはこういうポイントなんですね
だからお釈迦様は一応ものすごいこの話術を持っていて
人間っていうのはもうどんな風に喋れば喋れば理解するか
集中して話を聞いてくれるかっていうところは知っていたみたいし
そこら辺で詩で言う場合
言うべき時は詩で言うし
ものすごい感動的な言葉で言う時は
言うべき時はそういう風に喋るし
すごい厳密に何かもう授業みたいで
論理的に分析して喋る喋るべき時はそういう風に喋るという風に
あらゆる方法を喋っているんですね
それでこの話術に話術に惹かれて
で たくさん弟子 を入れてくれるっていうのは
まあ世の中は大体話術だけで十分ですよ
まあ大体どんな人でもものすごく上手に言葉を使うんだったら
それで人間としては十分ですよ
で 喋る内容はどうでもいいんです
ですから 世の中大体要求しているのは上手に喋る
喋ってるかないかっていうことなんですね
ですから この 内容では決してありません
だからもうこの世の中でうまく人気者で
ものすごく収入もあって
どんな仕事でも金儲かるためになるものだから
ものすごく収入を得て生活したければ
やっぱりまあ言葉を上手に喋る
上手に書く 内容はまるっきり関係ない
内容なんか入っちゃうともう困るんですよ
結局は ですから このすごいもう世界的なもうそういう優秀なね
書き屋さんとかね 喋る人やと言っちゃうと
まるっきり何も内容を喋れませんね
内容ないんですよ 内容ないんだけど
1時間でも2時間でも3時間も喋り続けることは大したもんですよ
だからいろんなところには引用しますよ
引用しただけでびっくりして
いきなり数字を出しちゃって
で そこでものすごいびっくりして
まただから何ということじゃなくて
そうやってこの まあ大体テレビのアナウンサーやらね
もう喋ることを見ると
もうすごく そういう風にこの何とかのあの番組でなんか手紙はあのたくさん来てましたと
1万ちょっと枚数なんですけど
それぐらいの手紙来ていたんです
だからかなりみんな見ているんだよっていう風にある男が言うと
女の人はということは 1億何とか何とかで全然見てないってことですねとかね
だから手紙出したのは1万人ぐらいだから
日本人口からね それを引いて
それでみんなすごく楽しくて拍手するんで
その言葉に それは話術っていうことなんですね
だからあの女にそこら辺にいて
誰かがディレクターが
じゃあお前はこういう風に喋りなさいと
お前はこういう風にこの番組を引き立てなさいと 2万人の返事がありましたと
なんとこんなにあると思わなかったんですよと
そしたらあの女がすごい四角い顔で
ということは  1億何とか何とか見てないってことですねとかね
で まあまあ そういうふうに
それでみんなもうすごい抜群な番組だと
結局何言ってるんだい
それでっていうことはね
だからかなり話術でないと
そういうふうに話すっていうことはできないんですね
だからそれだけで十分なんですよ
人間にとっては だから決してこの意味を通じるということは
もう世の中では存在しないんですね
ですから 意味を書いても読まないんですよ
だからただ言葉で何か間違いでもありますかとか
それだけ調べているだけでね
まあだからそれはもう残念なことに
遠い昔のお釈迦様は知っていたんですね
話術というものは世の中でちゃんとあることで
で 悪いことに お釈迦様にもすごい言葉
上手でしたし だからもうものすごいもう大量に人が集まるということはもう避けられないんですね
話を聞くために 面白いということで
で そういうで お釈迦さんはそれはもう嫌で嫌で
追い出したいんですね
だから私の弟子いる人
入り人いる人々が決してこのこの話術を目指して来てはいけませんと
だから スッタゲジェヴェヤカラムというのは話術っていうわけじゃなくて
お釈迦様の説法そのものなんですよ
説法を目指して来るなよっていうことなんです
で 本当の意味は説法っていうことですね
師は説法しているんではないか
じゃあ説法を聞きましょうという意味で弟子入りしてはいけませんと
なんででしょうかね そういう話を聞く目的で来るなよと言っているのは
で この法というのは 説法っていうのは一つの知識的な勉強なんですね
話術だけではないんです
ディーガラタッサヒョワアナンタダンマスタ
この法というものはディーガラッタ
もう長い間みんなもうよく聞いて勉強しているんですよ
ダッタ それから覚えてるんですね
それからワチャサパリジタ
ワチャサというのは発音して発音してお釈迦様の教えをね
唱えて唱えて ものすごく自分でそれパリジタ訓練しているんですね
だからお釈迦様の教えをもう長い間ものすごく聞いて聞いて
それから理解も覚えておく
暗記もして 暗記しただけではなくて
訓練もするんですね 発音して発音して発音して訓練もしています
マナサーヌペッキタ それだけじゃなくて
頭の中で考えることもしているんですね
どんな意味かと それからディッティアスッパティヴィッダ
ディッティアっていうのは
この このお釈迦様のビジョンをよく理解する
自分でも同じビジョンを得るっていうことなんですね
これは現代人はやらないことで
で 人の話をね 聞いて勉強すると
ただ聞いてテープラコーダーに入れておいて
どこかに捨てるということで全てわかったことにはなりませんし
あるいはただ何回何回も回して
まあこの人の声を聞くとよく眠れますよという
この睡眠薬代わりに使うとかね
それも勉強ということにはならないし
で まあわちらの話はどうせ意味がないんだからそれでいいんですけど
やっぱりどこかにね 学校やらどこかに人の話なんか聞く場合はね
で その人々はちゃんと大事な話をしていますね
ですから 人の話を聞いて
ただもう何とか聞いて聞いてわかっただけでは足らないんですよ
だからマナサー マナサーヌペッキタっていうのは
自分の頭でも なるほどなるほど
そういうことか そういうことかというふうに頭でいろんな思索していることなんですね
ですから 耳で聞く それから頭で覚えておく
それから自分で口でもその言葉を唱えて
まあもう習ってみる 訓練してみる
それで頭でもなんとか理解しようとすることはマナサーヌペッキタ
ディッティアスッパティヴィッダっていうことは大体はやりません
ディッティアっていうのは見だと書いていると思いますけど
日本訳は あの その人のビジョンなんですね
この人はどんな哲学 どんなビジョンを持ってるかという
その思想体系に自分がぎっしりと入り込んで
それをそのまま あ こういうことを教えてるんだというふうに理解することなんですね
そうすると 初めてその人の教えを勉強したことになります
だから鵜呑みにする意味ではないんです
だから一般的に私の感想では
なんかみんなそこはもう西洋思想でない限りは
この この論理を理解することをすごく嫌がるんですね
なんでそんな汚いことを理解してしなくちゃあかんかとかね
西洋思想だったら もう我が師匠のように
なんかすごい思い上がってやってるでしょうね
だからそれでもわかってないっていうことは私は思いますけどね
ただ猿真似だけではないかと
だから人の話を理解するってことはもうちょっと違うんですよ
で まあキリスト教の教えを勉強したいと思うならば
やっぱりその思想がどのように考えて
どんな哲学で どんな論理で
どういうふうになっているかっていうことが身についてないと勉強したことにならないんですね
そういうふうに勉強すれば
自分がキリスト教でね
なくても まあこういう質問が出てきた時だったらこういう答え出しますよと
ちゃんとこの思索 思想パターンというのは身につくんですね
だから人々はもう何か経験があって喋ってますからね
その中に入って理解しないと意味がないんです
ただ その人はこういう言葉言いました
こういう言葉言いましたとかね
ですから この我々インド系の人々は
あなたはこういう言葉を言ったのではないかと掛かってくると
その瞬間でもうもうゴミにしているんです
相手を で 一応答えるんだけど
もうただのもう生ゴミ
知識がないんだと だから大事なことはもう何か言葉がこういうことを言ったってそれじゃないんですよ
法律じゃないんだから
この思索というか この中身の哲学なんですね
だから中身の哲学で あなたはこういうこと言うんだけど
こういう風に見ると なんかちょっと納得いかないよと言っちゃうと
この人は中身にぶつかっているんだと
そこですごく面白くなってくるんですね
だから 昨日勉強に来たあの男性の質問はね
やっぱりそう言って 本当に中身の中身の中身のもうすごい難しいんですよ
そこはもう誰も気がつかないところで
でももう淡々と質問する
でもそれはきちんと中身を聞くんですね
そうすると すぐ淡々とこちらでも答えるしか方法ないんですね
あれやこれやとかね もう言う必要なくなっちゃうし
実はそうなってるのはこういうわけですよと
こうなってるのはこういうわけですよと
だから 表面的に見るとなんかブッダの教えに真っ向から逆らって質問するように聞こえます
でもそうじゃないんです
その人は別に真っ向から逆らうとかどっちかことじゃなくて
まあただお釈迦様の思想体系
お釈迦様自身の哲学に対して
自分が見出したちょっとした矛盾というか
何とかというそこら辺なんですね
だから言葉に引っかかってきたわけじゃないんです
まあそういうことで このお釈迦様の教えっていうのは
そういう順番でみんなやってるんだと
暗記するは覚えていくは
弟子たちと一緒に唱えているは
それから理解しようともするは
それからその思想体系の中に入り込んで
まあブッダの世界はこういう世界だと
ブッダに見られた世界はこういう世界
ブッダに見られた人生観はそういう人生観だという風に
その中にまで入って哲学まで勉強しているんだと
みんな長い間 ということで
何です 何をおっしゃりたいんですかね
このバラサカ様は だからお釈迦様の教えを勉強したければ
私のところに弟子入りしなくても
そこら辺の教会に行って神父さんに会ったっても
仏教ぐらいは勉強できますよ
だってその人も本なんか持ってますからね
仏教のテキストやら何か勉強したければ
もうどこら辺もカトリック教会に行ってみたっても
おそらくパリのパリであろうか
日本校の仏典やらもあると思いますよ
金持ちのところだから
ヴァティカンに行ってももうかなり仏典いろいろあると思いますよ
あるものをそれぞれの専門家にさせてたって
みんなそれなりに勉強したりはしています
だから さっとブッダに弟子入りとかね
誰かお坊さんに話を聞く必要全くない
そこら辺に行けばいいんです
もっとすごい贅沢にかっこよく勉強することもできると思いますね
だから勉強ぐらいだったらどこででもできるんだよということなんです
そこで厳密に あの 何て言いますか
理屈 論理をもう理解したいという
まあ西洋思想と比較しながら
何とか何とか思想と比較しながら
勝手にいくらでもどこでもできるんですよ
そんなもの だから それためにはブッダのところに来るなよと
どこら辺のもうもう大学もいっぱいあるし
全く仏教を信仰してないんですよ
もう大学の教授だって
でもものすごい世界的な仏教の教授なんですよ
私が知ってるのはみんなもう絶対輪廻なんかは信じません
なぜ 何でですか？アメリカではそんな話はないんだと
でもギリギリとブッダを読むんです
漢文で読むはサンスクリット語で読んでるわとかね
そこでも訂正までこのサンスクリット文章はそうじゃなくてこうなるべきですよとかね
すごい専門家なんですよ
まあアビダンマにしたってもね
ものすごい専門的な知識がありますよ
ですからまあこういうブッダのところには来るなよと
もうそんなにもうめんどくさいしね
そんなにもう学問的なもうやりたければ
もうそういう学者のところに行った方がいいというところなんですね
こちらで昔から言ってるのは
で それであの心配はないんだと
だってちゃんと教えてるテキストできてるんだから
それは何人語それテキストを読んでみたっても変化できませんだから
そういう心配はないんですよ
だから英語でもフランス語でもパーリ経典でもいろいろ訳はあります
英語だったら全部訳あるし
まあドイツ語か何語か今またいくつか訳しているし
昔はもうソ連のロシア語でもいろいろありましたからね
それでも昔はいたんですよ
仏教学者が すごい立派な本
ものすごいもう驚くほど立派な本とか書かれてありましたし
一応日本英訳もあるしね
ロジックというテキストはもうソ連人の学者書いたもんで
あれはインドのサンスクリット語にあったロジックの本をね
翻訳したのってなかなか難しいんですよ
ちゃんとロシア語にありましたしね
ですから そういう人々に行って勉強してもらえば
もう立派に学問的に教えてくれるんですね
うん だから心配はないと
そこら辺長い間それはもう確定して対策する方法までもう確定しているんだからね
教えはね お釈迦様にとってはおすべき
なんかもう子供たちが勉強に学校に来たような感じでお釈迦様のところに来ると
これやりきれないんですよ
来るなよと 学校っていくらでもあるんだからね
そちらに行って勉強しなさいということで
ヤー
チャコーアヤンアーナンダカタアビサンレーキカーチェトーヴィヴァルナサッパーヤーエーカンタニンビダーヤヴィラーガーヤニローダーヤウパサマーヤアヴィンニャーヤサンボーダーヤニッバーナーヤサンワッタティー
そこでまたお釈迦様のところに弟子入りすれば
またお釈迦様がいろんなことを話はしますよ
お釈迦様はこのスッタニパータからではなくて
この話術でいろいろ喋るんではなくて
学者で教授でいろんなことを喋るんじゃなくて
ごく一般的なイランのことを喋るんだと
それはどういう話かというと
アビサンレーキター アビサンレーキターってのはね
削って減らしたものに削り取って減らしていく
削減の話  その削減の意味だけ
はぁ 削減の話って何ですかね
余分なものを削り取るって解釈したらダメですか
だからこれ日本語訳しているんだから日本語で何か意味が通るでしょうね
おそらく  通るような通らないような
私はずっと自分の訳つけてきたんだけど
誰も相手にしなかったしね
これいいと思っていたし
これで決めたんです 私は教える方法を
日本語訳を中心にするんだぞと
手本にしてやっちゃおうと思って
でも私はわからないんだから
削減の話って何でしょうかと
まあパーリ語でわかってますけどね
まあでも 一応パーリ語でこのアビサルレキタという言葉は
あの日本語で削減という風になってます
で だからといってパハ―ね
減るとかね その時も削減という言葉を使いますけど
あの それと同じじゃないと思いますけどね
で この辞書を引いてみたっても
必ず同じ言葉が出てくると思います
削減のとか もう一つ 尊厳のと尊厳のっていうこともありますけどね
うん 何かね いい言葉がないかな
ないと思いますけどね
削減の話って言えばどういう話でしょうかね
あの 減らすじゃいけないんです
ん？ 減らすじゃいけない
だから減らすお話ってどういう話ですかね
リストラ  え？ リストラ
[笑い]話の太さを神髄に向かって無駄なものを一つずつ減らしていく
だったら結局喋らない方がいいでしょうに
喋らなきゃ困るんです
肝心なところは  喋る場合は肝心なところだけ喋って黙っているのはあまり失礼でしょうしね
明確に説明して喋るのは正しい
相手がわからなかったり
そのことを喋っても相手がわからなかったり
余分なことも喋らないと理解できない人もいるかもしれないし
だから減らすことについて話す
減らすことについて この言語を分解したらいかがでございますか
だから学者の頭の中には学者様方はアビサルレキタっていうことは
そうやって削減という風に翻訳しているんだから
まあそれはそれは私が何回言ったっても認められませんでしょうね
それはそれなりってことになって
私は何言ったってもそれもう意味がないんです
まあとにかく学者に言えるものは学者にいるところで
で まあ注釈書を見ても意味がないんでしょうし
まあだから注釈書を見ても出てこないと思います
だから学者はいくら翻訳したって今翻訳できないんです
注釈書で出てこないのは
それなりのわけがあるんです
そういうものは他のところで
別な場所でちゃんと翻訳注釈しているんです
ですから 仏教の人々は知ってるんです
意味は そこで出るたびにそちらの翻訳はしません
基本用語だから でも学者の場合はその場所で翻訳していないとわからない
その場所場所によって訳し方が違うということですか
その状況によって  そういう話じゃないんですけど
アビサルレキタという言葉の意味は
言葉の意味は出てこないんですよ
だから注釈書にはないんだから
でも他のところではあると思います
うん どうしようかな 何番だったこれは
何番？この経典は  経典は
百五十二条？コンテキストから見れば
後ろの方のため これはもうコンテキストから見なくちゃわかんないですよ
そこだけ言ったって  だから私には日本語の言葉を思い出せないんですよ
別にパーリ語から見れば全然何の問題もない言葉ですよ
日本語訳ではそうなってますけど
パーリ語的には何のこともない
この前も何回も出ましたし
この勉強会で私はアビッサンレーギタっていうことを説明したんですよ
聞き覚えがありますけど
なんかかっこいい言葉がないんですからね
アビッサンレーギタっていうのはこの平素という意味ではありません
で これは道徳的な人の生き方について喋る時の使う言葉であって
まあしつけというか もうもうまあ
そういう日本語の場合も言葉がないんですね
説法はあるんだけど もうお話っていう言葉があるんだけど
話もいろいろあるんですよ
人間が何をするべきか
何をしてはいけないかということは淡々と喋る
アドバイスの話がありますよ
で アドバイスと言っちゃうと
また日本語でまた変な意味でしょうに
ですから もうまあ 本当の英語の意味ではもうアドバイスですよ
リプリマンドという言葉もあります
アドバイスという言葉もあります
うーん だから法の場合はドクトリンとかね
もうという色々もあります
その一つ一つ各言葉の意味合いが違うんですね
で リプリマンドという言葉なんですよ
諭すっていうのは違いますか
諭すっていう  リプリマンドは諭すじゃないんですよ
わきまえる  うん ね まあ辞書でもあればね
調べますけどね おそらくリプリマンドだと思いますね
英語の言葉は で あの 一応アドバイスすることで
この人間はいろんなことをやって生活しているんですよ
そこはもうあまりにも良くなくて
あまりにも良くなくて
もう堕落するんですね
そこでどういう風に生きていればいいかとかわからないんですね
そこで喋ってあげるんですよ
こういうこういうものは削減しなさいと
この子の行動をやめなさいと
喋る場合は喋ってもいいんだけど
こういう話し方は削減しなさいと
食べてもいいんだけど
こういう食べ方は削減しなさいと
歩いてもいいんだけど
こういう歩き方はやめなさいという風に
とことんもう生き方 喋る
だから削減という言葉になってるんですけど
削減という意味ではないんですね
結局は 一応話の中でこういうこういう言葉戒めなさい
自習しなさいと  この前の前に削減って日本語で出てきた時に
確かそのように先生からお聞きしたっていうのを今なんとなく思い出して
で 私はその時物事をわきまえるってことかなって心の中でちょっと思ったんです
まあ日本語ではないでしょうね
叱るというぐらいしかないんですけど
日本語だったら  叱るっていうので近寄るとしつけるとか
しつけ叱る  はい そういった感じの方向に行きます
うん やっぱりレプリマンドはこちらもね
なんとか何か戒と書いてますけど
読めない 戒戒わからない
叱るとなんとかですね
漢字なんかあります  思い出しました
確か先生がそういう風にご説明いただいたと思いました
レプリマンドで場所を探す大変な時間がかかるんです
頑張って 紹介 叱責 紹介する
戒めるというような意味ですね
しつける 日本人の間ではやっぱりわきまえがないから
こういうことをしつけるとか
そういう意味じゃないかと思います
だからちゃんとわきまえあって
それはすごい何となくかっこいい言葉で
もうそれじゃないんですね
しつけることを懲戒ですよ
懲戒でいいと思いますね
あまりかっこいい言葉ではないんです
懲戒という言葉は普段生活の中で出てこない
しつけるっていうのは
よく子供をしつけるとか
そういう意味では使いますけど
でも懲戒とは意味が強いですよ
そうそう 懲戒免職とかだからじゃない
申し渡して諭すとか そういう意味で
いやもうちょっと意味がね
悪い方に そういう風に解釈すればね
懲戒免職とか 後から免職って言葉を聞くと
懲戒免職って続けて解釈すればいい言葉ではない
懲戒っていうのはあまり強いので
だからアドバイスでいいんじゃないですか
アドバイスでいいんですけど
アドバイスは日本語じゃないんですけど
みんな知ってるから でも先生のおっしゃりたい奥のあれは
やっぱり私たちで受け取りにくい部分があるんだと
先生の中ではもうお分かりになってて
日本語のアドバイスはまあなんとなくすごいこの
あまりにも軽すぎ まあ懲戒なんですけど
まあ懲戒といっても漢字
漢字としてはね また意味がガタガタで完璧じゃないし
まあ懲戒ほどのものでもないんですけど
まあアドバイス懲戒の中間ぐらいなものなんです
忠告するとか  忠告  戒めるっていうような感じ
まあ戒めの話ですよ まあ一般的に言えばね
戒めですよ 説法はするんだけど
もう完全に戒め中心にやるというね
これからどうするべきかというふうな話なんですね
次の言葉はチェトー・ヴィワラナ・サッパーヤ
チェトー 心 ヴィワラナっていうのはこのガードすることですね
えーと 削減 心の障害を離れるためにふさわしい
チェトー・ヴィワラナ
サッパーは相応しい まあこの場合も伝統的にこの日本訳も南部やってますけど
やっぱり言語 言葉から見れば
これは心をガードするという意味でいいと思います
けど ヴィヴァーリテっていうのはプロテクションというね
まあ言われれば何々か危険から守るということで入らないようにする
だから心を一応警備しておくんですね
心を警備する場合は 敵が外から来るんですね
だから障害と言えば 心の中にも障害あるやるんですね
うん ですから チェーと言われるのっていうのは
ここチェーとは心です
心に警備をつける 敵が入らないようにという
いわゆるまあここは簡単には心の障害なんですけど
心の障害を取り除くためにサッパーやサポートになるもの
ですから まあ現代日本訳すれば
心を警備に当たる話 心をどのように警備すれば
護せれば守ればよろしいかという
その話を聞いたら すぐ心を守ることができるようになるんですね
それからエーカンタニッビダーヤ
お釈迦様が話す場合は
この話はエーカンタ極端に一方的にニッビダーヤ解脱にいくんですね
いわゆるこのあれこれと人の話にはめげない
全然もうそう言われたっても仕事をしなくちゃあかんだと
そういう生ぬるい話は聞かない
だったら仕事辞めなさいと
お釈迦様はこうやって解脱しなさいと言ったっても
うちの奥さんは結婚してだって捨てなさいと
それ言い訳は何一つも聞かない
エーカンタっていうのはabsoluteということで
もう一方通行を徹底的に涅槃を目指している解脱を目指している話なんですね
だからエーカンタニッビダーヤ
ヴィラーガヤっていう言葉にもエーカンタ入るんで
エーカンタ全部に入ります
ヴィラーガヤ 怨嗟 欲から離れる
徹底的に徹底して欲から離れる話をする
次にニローダーヤ 滅ですね
煩悩をなくすこと だから徹底的に煩悩をなくす方向へ喋る
ウパサーマーヤ 徹底的に平安の安らぎのために喋る
アヴィンヤーヤ 徹底したこの超越した智慧
俗世間の智慧じゃなくて
この超越した智慧を目指して話をしていますね
サンボーダーヤ 悟りのために喋る
ニッバーナへ 涅槃のために喋ると
三輪車でそういうものに導く
だからお釈迦様の話は徹底的に一方通行的に何に導くかというと
ニッビダーヤ ニッビダーヤっていうのはこの面白くなくなるんですよ
ニッビダーヤっていうのは面白くないって意味なんです
まあ嫌だと思うこと いわゆる世の中
俗世間で溺れてもう遊んでいる生活についてはものすごくもう嫌悪感
嫌悪感 なんて気持ち悪くて嫌なものだという心はもう俗世間からきちっと逆に返ってもらうんですね
だからニッビダっていうのはものすごく代弁食べさせるようなぐらいの感情なんですよ
ありがたいとお醤油ぐらい入れちゃえば食べられますよとか
そんな話じゃないんですよ
すごい嫌なんですね それを強引に食べさせると
もう食べなかったら殺すかもしれませんと
殺されるかもしれない
食べると食べるかもしれませんだけど
イライラでやってますよ
だからニッビダっていうのはそれぐらいの感情なんです
俗世間についてはものすごい嫌悪感を感じて
ものすごい なんかもうもうヒンドゥーだなくて嫌という風に
だからお釈迦さんの話はやっぱり一応そういうふうな方向へ導いてあって
それからEkanda Nibbida viraga
や欲がなく穏理のことで
で Sanwa nirodhaや煩悩はなくなる Upasama
や心は平安になる Abhinna
超一流な出世間な知恵
出世間的な知恵が生まれる Sambodha
や悟りが生まれる Nibbana
や涅槃に至るという話するんですね
だからお釈迦様のところに弟子入りすれば
厳密に仏教学問は聞いてくれませんね
教えてくれません 四聖諦はありきやとかね
それもう苦聖は苦 聖諦はなんぞやとかね
それはこれ こういうものでありとかね
そこで小空とはなんぞやとかね
そんなのはもうないんです
どこら辺に誰で そこら辺に行って誰かから勉強してこいと
そんなものは だからこの仏教は学問としての話を理解するためには来るなよと
そんなものは長い間 お釈迦様は説いて定めて
もうこれがテキストだというふうにしているんですよ
若い時も全部仏教はこれぐらいやと
全部さささっと投げて
テキストはテキストはないんだけど
一応誰の中でも仏教 仏説はこれですということは認めてまとめてもう整えてあったんです
だからそれはもう誰からでも聞いたらわかりますよと
みんなもう勉強形だからね
仏教を理解したければ
別にお釈迦様のところに行く
そこら辺のヒンドゥー教のどこかのジャイナ教の誰かのところに行ったっても
すぐわかっているんですよ
もうシャマナはこういうことをおっしゃってますよと
勉強ぐらいは だからそんなのを勉強するために私のところに来るんじゃないと
私のところに来るんだったら
すごいすごい力強く ものすごい攻撃的で
ものすごいもう爆弾的に
お釈迦様 個人的には喋ってるんですよ
だからAbhisallEkittaという言葉っていうのは
みんな聞いて嫌がって逃げるぐらいのきつい話なんです
時々お釈迦様の話はあまりにもきつすぎてAbhisallEkittaアヤンシャムノゴと悪口まで言うんですよ
お釈迦様やりすぎやと
そこまで言う必要はないんだと
で だからAbhisallEkittaという言葉はパーリ語と語にしたっても
あんまりあの愛情のある言葉じゃない
あまり気に入られる言葉じゃないんですよ
これは懲戒 懲戒なんですよ
懲戒というのは日本語でもすごくなんかもう嫌な言葉でしょうに
だから懲戒を重んじる話なんですよ
だから恐ろしい 怖い ビシビシよ
甘いとか なんとか優しいとか
ひとかけらもない 宗教だからもうちょっと優しく
もうちょっと手柔らかにとかね
もうちょっと信者さんのことを礼をしてとかね
神社の宮司さんみたいにね
仏教では絶対そんなことはないんです
ブッダのところでは 穏やかな言葉とかね
全然一つもない だから人は貶しませんよ
人は貶しません なんてますか
侮辱はしません それ勘違いしてほしい
人は侮辱しないというのは
これは常識ですけどね
だからすごく なんていうんですか
温厚な何とか何とかとかね
円満なとか すごく心に優しい
一つもないんですけど
だからそこら辺は誤解してほしくない
厳しいんですよ 厳しいと言ったって
お前この野郎死んでしまえとかね
そういう品のない話じゃないんです
だからそういう個人のね
プライドを傷つけて 個人の人格を壊しちゃったりしてね
そういうこのもうヤクザみたいなね
そういう話はしませんと
これはものすごい知識的な知恵の話なんですけど
甘い話にはなりませんね
これはやめることとかやめなさいと
やめたくないんだったら出て行きなさいと
あんた成長したければ
こういうこういう決まりはやりなさいと
ちょっとといったって私の腰が痛い
だったら帰ると じゃあもう出て行け
出て行けと 今とはものすごく違うんですよ
だから 例えば若いお坊さんたちが遠くから来て
まあ来たばっかりだからちょっと声が高かったんです
もうちょっとまあなんとかなんとか喋ったんですよ
自分の仲間の間で お釈迦様から見ると
ちょっと声がでかい ほんのちょっとでかかっただけ
ほんのちょっとお釈迦様いるところに声が届いた
ただそれだけなんですよ
その会場っていうのはすごい大きいところでしたから
あの お釈迦様いた部屋は
まあそれも結構大きい部屋でした
今もありますけどね で
そちらにあっちこっちで森の誘いのお坊さんたちの声が聞こえたんですよ
いきなり誰ですか？の声出したのと
それはあの遠く遠くからもう何ヶ月もかけて若いお坊さんたちがグループが来ているんだと
ああ 追い出しなさい これは私のところにいるべきではありませんと
さまのゴータマのバカはってやつの場合ね
釈迦様のところではいるいてはいけませんと
追い出しますと もう顔も合わせてないんですね
しょうがないんですよ
それでも アナンダ尊者にそれを言われたら
アナンダ尊者がサーリプッタ尊者に
もうそういうことにお釈迦様はこういうことを
あ そうですかと じゃあ帰りますと
何のことなく追い出されたらもう帰ってしまったんですね
だから阿鼻叫喚ってのはそういうことでもう厳しい
もう並じゃないんです
同じことを二度と言うなよと言ったならば
もう殺されても言わない方がいいんだよ
お釈迦様の前に これは言うなよと言ったんではないかと
聞くなよと言ったんではないかと
その厳しさ 世の中で誰のところもないんですよ
でなきゃこの怠け者というのは育てられませんしね
いかに人間で気持ち悪くて屁理屈と言うと
もう もうもう悟りの世界
智慧の世界じゃないんですよ
もう瞑想会に来る時はもう2週間前に私はもう菜食主義で有機栽培の食べ物しか食べません
それで聖者ぶるんですか？とある人はそういう話を聞いてね
だから私は電話を受けなかったんだから
ですから 私電話を受けたら
ではあなたは来ないでくださいと
あなたの面倒を見る暇がないんだよと
誰かさんが菜食主義で有機栽培で
この何とか豆 バイオティックスの食べ物しか食べないんだと
だからそのバカのためにこちらでマイトバイオティック食べ物を用意しておかないと
そのバカがもう億年修行したっても
ひとかけらも進みませんよ
そのわがままで これ知ってますから
ですから私がということをしたら
もういいや あなたは来なくてもと
家でやってくださいと
それで本人はそうですか
では私は家でやりますと
家で何やるんですかね
テキストにあるんですかね
お釈迦様の瞑想法は テキストに書けませんよ
テキストにあると思うのは勘違いです
ですから この厳しいっていうのはそういうことなんですよ
そこで一応私はもうだったらかなり困りますよというところで
では自分の食べ物を全部持ってくるんですよということで
食べ物食べ物あれやこうやって持ってきて
ずっとイライライライライライラ状態でね
2日  3日いて帰っちゃうんですね
怒りの瞑想してね だから本当に私は優しくはないんですよ
だから黙ってるんですね
どうぞどうぞと 好きなものを召し上がってくださいと
お休みしたければどうぞ休んでくださいと
あれはみんな優しく優しいやと思ってるでしょ
優しくないんです ああいう風な言葉用と
もう人間扱いしていないんですよ
だから親切にすごく 寝たければどうぞ
はい おねんねと そういう態度なんです
だからお釈迦様は優しかったんだから
もうそれとは違いますよ
出て行けと そんなに だから死ねと
はっきり言うんですよ
だから死ねと 例えば食べ物にちょっとちょっと
もうちょっと まあなんとか目がない
お前刀みたいなものを持って腹を切って死になさいよと
そんなこと食うんだったら
お坊さんたちは食べ物にちょっと執着しちゃうでしょうに
美味しいご飯もらうところにちょっとちょっと托鉢にとか何回になんか行ったりすると
石を真っ赤に焼いて 鉄の玉をね
鉄の玉を真っ赤に焼いて食いなさいよと
どうったことない お前死ぬだけやと
なんどうったことないと
食べ物に執着するなよと
だからそれがもう言葉に絡めればどれほどきついかと
だから現代語ではお前死んだっても全然気にしませんよと
その方がいいやと 死んでしまえと
こちら来るなよというぐらいの話なんです
だからお釈迦様が言うのは
私が追い出しても 追い出しても
否定しても 否定しても
私のところに それでもみんななぜ来るべきかというと
この話を聞くために来るべきですよと
アビサリー来た話を エーカント
ヴィラーガ ニロダ ニッバーナ
アヴィンヤーヤ ニッバーナへサンワッタティという話を聞くために来るべきですよと
因果法則をうんぬんぞやとかね
もう輪廻はなんなのかとかね
五蘊とはもう五蘊は五蘊ですか
本当に十個 十蘊ですかとかね
そういう話は誰から勉強しなさい
ですから この弟子入りだから
やっぱりこのすごい師弟関係で
もう生々しい関係なんですよ
学問的な関係って生々しくはないんですよ
単なる遊びだけのこと
知識的なね ですから お釈迦様に直々に会った人々っていうのは
もう まあたとえ鬼がもう 1万匹いたっても全然気にしないと思いますよ
あらゆる所から恐ろしい鬼が立ちかけて
もうあなたを脅してやると
もうあんたのことなんのことはない
あんたのこと全然もう気にしちゃいなさいと
こちらの方がものすごい怖いと
それくらいもうきつく育てたんです
だからそのきつさっていうのは
お釈迦様はすごい もうもうきつい言葉を使ったこと自体がお釈迦様の限りない慈しみの慈悲であって
ですから この 私は毎日朝 7時
8時に起きますから もう瞑想できっこないんだとか何とか言っちゃうと
そうですね しょうがないんですね
もう慣れていることだからと私は必ず言いますよ
それ自体 この中で一番不親切な言葉なんですよ
食って寝るためだから家で食って寝ればいいし
瞑想会では5時に送るんだったら
たとえその人はもう80年間7時8時まで寝ていたっても
瞑想会に来たら5時に起きることなんですよ
正しく指導するんだったら 5
時に起きてないんだったら
その場で荷物をまとめて追い出すこと
出て行きなさいと 今すぐ
それぐらいやらないと人を育てることはできないんです
それぐらい心っていうのは汚くて怠けているんです
それで弟子関係 お釈迦様にはお釈迦様のところに弟子入りする場合は
お釈迦様のありがたいお説法を聞くためではありません
お釈迦様とちょっとご一緒に生活するんですよ
そばではいませんだけど
まあそこら辺 他のそこら辺の周りで生活している
でもお釈迦様がいるところで生活しているんだから
喉を鳴らすことさえも禁止なんですよ
それほど楽じゃないんです
とか喉を鳴らす それはダメなんです
お釈迦さんはそれでも誰ですかと
音を立てたなと その厳しいさダメじゃないんですよ
ですから みんなもう本当にもう
例えば風邪なんか引いて咳が出ても
すごい苦労して音を立てないように頑張ってるんです
全然お釈迦様にこれぐらいは病気だからしょうがないでしょうとは一言言ったら
もうそれで終わり もう出てきて
お前 私のところにいるべき人ではありませんと
怠け者やと だから一番難しいのはくしゃみなんですよ
くしゃみはしないんだから
お釈迦様のところで誰一人も
まあ咳ぐらいはなんとかなんとか
くしゃみはどうしますかね
くしゃみが出ても どうせ埃やらいっぱいあるところで
普通に座ってね 地面に座ってるでしょうに
くしゃみが出てもみんなとにかく我慢して我慢して
鼻をなんとかして なんとかして
これをもう音を立てないように気をつけるんです
だからそれぐらい神経やると悟らないと思いますか？だからみんなもう何のことなく淡々と悟るんです
だからお釈迦様とばれたら
まあ 1日2日でもほとんど終わりますからね
悟る 悟ったところで お釈迦様は何のことなくすごく褒めてあげるんだからね
完全に悟り開いたらね
すごく褒めてあげるし
それでもこちらにいる
いる ないということでね
そこがもう自由にしなさいと
それでみんな自由に生活するんですよ
托鉢して何か召し上がって
気楽に瞑想もしながら
それで生活はする 修行中ということで
お釈迦様のところに弟子入りに行ったら
もう命の覚悟でいた方がいいんです
死ぬか悟るかどちらにするのでしょうということやで
だからそれでありがたいことは
この仏教ではね 仏教のお釈迦様も考えている
この師弟関係っていうのはそんなもんです
だからそういう話はどんな話かというと
このスッタンゲイヤンゲイヤーカラナンジャータカンウダーナンアブダダンマンウェードウェーダッランとかなんとかという九つの法とか
いわゆる学問的な法ですね
その代わりにお釈迦様が修行するとき喋る説法はアッピッチカタサントゥッティカタ
アッピッチカタ アッピッチャっていうのはもう小欲の話
やっぱりそれはもう論理的にも対策的に思想として生き方として小欲は喜ぶこと
サントゥッティカタっていうのはもう何でしたっけ？知足のこと
小欲と知足 パヴィウェーカカタ
パヴィウェーカカタっていうのは
やっぱり一人で生活することは一番ありがたいと
いろんなもうたくさん仲間を作る話ではなくて
たくさん仲間を作って
建物を造って 家を造って
もう贅沢する贅沢ではなくて
楽に生活するなんていう話ではなくて
離れましょう 離れましょうと
友達から離れましょうと
一人で生活しましょうという話ですね
アサンサッガカタ サンサッガっていうのはみんなと交わすというかね
交わす話なんですね 仲良くする話で
アサンサッガっていうのは
みんなからどうすれば離れて離れて離れて一人で生活できるんでしょうかという
ヴィリヤアランバカタ
努力精進の話 シーラカタ
自分を戒める話 サマーディカタ
禅定の話 パンニャーカタ
智慧の話 それからヴィモッティカタ
解脱の話とヴィモッティニャーナダッサナカタ
解脱を得た人の智慧の話
智慧二種類ですよ シーラサマーディパンニャーのパンニャー
シーラは戒 サマーディは定
パンニャーは慧 戒めの話でサマーディの話と智慧の話ですね
それから解脱の話が出てきて
それから解脱を得た人の話
智慧の話がまた出てくるんです
このような話はブッダがするんだと
その話を聞いて勉強するために
私に私が追い出しても追い出しても
私のところに来て弟子として修行した方がいいと
じゃあこれで今日で終了にしましたね
もう一つ  欠けてもない
うん OK なんかないな
うん まあどうしますかね
かなり長いな ねぇ  全部終了に持ってきますかね
10分で終了することになります
で 一応そのように弟子入りするんですね
また次にストーリーとつなげていくと
このようであれば アーナンダよ
師の災いが生じますと
これから次の問題に持っていくんです
師の えーと 何でしたっけ
師の災いが生じます このようであれば
弟子の災いが生じます
このようであれば 梵行者の災いが生じます
ではアーナンダよ どのように師の災いが生じるのか
というところで 師弟関係の次の問題
とにかく師弟関係であろうが
関係だから決していいものじゃないんですよ
苦しみが生まれるんですよ
どんな関係でも 生命との関係っていうのは苦しみの災いの元なんです
それ たとえお釈迦様と弟子との関係だとしたって関係だからね
そういうことで あらゆるこのウパッダ
災いが生まれてくるんだと
だから師から出てくる災い
めんどくさいこと それからアンテワーシ
この弟子のいろんな性格の悪さから
いろんなトラブルが出てくる
ブラフマチャリア・ウパッダワっていうのはやっぱり実践ですね
実践する 修行する そのものに
また関係なくいろいろ災いが生まれてくると
実践しようとするんだけど
何かトラブルが起こるということで
そこで師から生まれてくる災いは何なのかというと
イダ アーナンダ カタンチャ アーナンダ アーチャリユーパッドワゴ
師の災いは何なのか アーナンダ エカッチョー サッター ヴィヴィッタン セーナースナン バジャティ アランヤン ルッカムーラン パッバタン カンガタン
ある師が 離れている森やらね
木の下やら山やら もう動物やらね
お墓やら そういうどこかに人がいないところで生活するんですね
タッサ タターウパカッタッサ ヴィーラトー アナーヴァッタニ ブラーマナ ガハパティカ アネーガ マーチェヴァ ジャナパダータ
ふんふんふんふんふんふん
まあそんな難しくないんだから
淡々と読めばいいんです
それで動物などなど生活しますね
あの 藁とかね 青汁の このように隠居して住んでいる彼の元に
町や地方のバラモン シサンカたちが訪ねてきます
彼は訪ねてくる町や地方のバラモン
シサンカたちに対して
迷いですかね 欲しかな
欲し むさぼり シャシに転じます
シャシって何だ？贅沢
え？贅沢？だから死 そういうことになるんだと
アーナンダよ これが災いのある死と言われます
死の災いによって汚れのある再生をもたらす恐ろしいこの果報を備えた未来に生まれ
生まれと老いと死がある
諸々の悪しき不善の法が彼を打ち
何でしたっけ？つけます
アーナンダよ このような死の
うん 日本語で読んだらわからなくなっちゃう
アワディンスナアム まあとにかくこの
悟れないっていうことでですね
言ってる なんか日本語で悟るんだっていう風に言ってるような感じがしたんだけど
それは読み違いかもしれませんですけど
死の災いによってよがるのある
果報を備えた未来に生まれるというがある
諸々の悪しき不善法が彼を打ちつけます
どういう意味ですか？不善法が打ちつけますね
それ負けるってことですね
そこで善逝はちょっと気が弱いんですね
で それでもう本当に欲のないきついもう藁の腐ってるところとか
そういうところで生活していたかもしれませんけども
そういうところにどうせもう俗人たちが来て
もう説法を聞いたりすると
いろいろいろいろまあ贅沢させちゃうと
だからみんな持ってくるものだからしょうがなく使っていて
やっぱりしょうがなく使うのはいいんだけど
自分も知らないうちに
この贅沢の生き方に引っ張られてしまうということになる
それは死の災いやと いわゆる心が生の脆いというところは
頑固じゃないんですよ
じゃああなた言うんだったら
まあせっかくだからちょっと酒一杯飲みましょうというね
このせっかくだからという一言葉でもう人間失格なんですよ
せっかくではなくて まあせっかく
それはもうせっかくだから失格なんですよ
だからまあ仏教ではせっかくだからってないんですよ
もしあったら まあもう失格です
うん ねぇ だからせっかくの論理っていうのはね
やっぱり相手のことを気にすることでしょ
いわゆる相手によって自分がすごく揺らぐっていうことなんですよ
だからそれだったらもう危険でしょうに
どんな場面でもせっかくになっちゃうんだからね
まあ断る時でも 日本ではね
せっかくですけど断りますという風にも言いますけどね
まあまあそれはその時はいいんですけどね
まあ一応そうやってね
社会からね いろんな贅沢やらいろんなものを持ってくると
なんとなくするすると心がそこら辺に回転してしまっちゃうと
もう心は誘惑されてる状態なんですね
その生 こんな弱い心で
まあもしかするとその先生は立派な先生で
あの もしかすると悟ってるかもしれませんよ
悟っていても もしかすると
まあちょっと贅沢にちょっと足が引っ張られるという
そういう先生のところに弟子入りした人はなかなかダメですよと
悟れないんだと だからその先生の性格にある
この微かな弱みというか
この緩いところが問題になるんだと
だから恐ろしく頑固でなきゃ
もう だから弟子たちが
例えばもう食べ物もなくて
お腹が空いていて そこで誰かが食べ物をやっぱり持ってきたんだと
先生から見れば ちょっとこの持ってきたやり方がちょっと間違ってると
あるいは弟子一人がちょっと誰かに話をしたんだと
本当は先生ってみんなもうもう二日もご飯も食べてないんだよとかなんか
それで先生はなんかそれ感知するという
こいつはなんか信者さんに言ったんではないかと
信者さんが別にそれとはあまり関係なく
やっぱりもうごちそうを持っていきましょうと
ごちそう持ってくる 先生だったら厳しくて食うなよと言うかもしれません
捨てなさいと 弟子たちは二日間も食べてないんだから
もうちょっと食べたってもいいんじゃないか
いえ 違います 食べてもよくないと
せっかくですから捨てなさいと
せっかくですけど それぐらい強くないと
育てることはできないんだよという話なんです
ですから 人間の性格バラバラだから
少々ちょっと調整してあげる人々っていうのは結構世の中でいるし
仏教ってかなり調整してあげるということをやってはいますよ
別に仏教は頑固な教えじゃないんだから
かなり調整しますよ 調整はするんだけど
師弟関係になると まあもう死んでしまえと
調整はなしと そこら辺は違うんですよ
それがあの先生の弱みですね
そうなるとなかなか悟れなくなっちゃうんだと
次は えーとえーとえーと
エヴ
ァンゴリンドラチェルワトカタンチャナンダアンテーヴァーすぱっどほーてぃたっさエーバコーパナナンダサットゥサーボたっさサットゥビウェカンアヌブルーハヤマー
ナヴィッタングセーナーサナンバジャティアランヤンルックムーンランパッバタンカンダーランビリグハンすさなンワナパッタンアッボーカサンパララプンジャンたっさ
タッターウーパカッタッサヴィーリトアナワットゥニ
同じことですね まあ弟子も弟子で
先生に従って森の中で一人で生活していると
もう苦労しながら修行している途中で
いろいろ在家の人々が来て拝んだりするところで
もし堕落しちゃうんだったら
もうそれでダメですよと
それからブラフマチャリアウパワウパッドゥ
ブラフマチャリア 修行の災いって何でしょうかと
じゃあこの二つをちょっと考えてください
で みんなこのみんなではなくて
この仏教にはもうちゃんと仏教を勉強していない
好き勝手に本を開けて読むだけの
ものすごい金メダルあげるべき
ノーベル賞をあげるべき天才たちが世の中にいるんですよ
だからほんまに何回読破して
これがOKやとかね で
だからもうすごい困りますけど
困ってはないんだけど
殺したいくらいの悪りい言い方言いますけど
ただ何か読んだだけで
それわかるわけじゃないんですよ
だからこれでもこの表面的に読めば
あの草木 例えば洞窟や藁の藁が腐っているところで
それで座り込んでいれば
それこそ修行はそれこそ悟りだという意味で取れるんですよ
そういう意味じゃないんです
だから基本的には人から何も認めない生活だから
森の中に 木の下に生活するのは当たり前で
すごく穏やかな気持ちで
これで十分やと あ 木の下があるんじゃないか
これで修行できるんだぞということは
それは基本中の基本で
で そこからもう木の下に満足していたい
いてほしいんですよ 喜びを感じていてほしいんですよ
この小欲知足が大事ですよ
それでまあ誰かが信者さんがね
木の下に何か敷物何もないでしょう
じゃあこれ敷いてこの上に座ってくださいと言ったら
捨てますということじゃないんですよ
で それを敷いてその上に座ってもいいんですけど
心変えてはいけないんですね
小欲知足の心は変えてはいけないんですよ
だからそれはきちんと守っておかないと
で どんどん品物入るたびに自分の生活基準
水準を自分で変えちゃうと
もう心が堕落しているんですね
だから徹底的に言ったらこの心の弱みなんですね
でないとジャイナ教と同じく
もうお布施を受け取るなよということにはなってしまっちゃうんですよ
木の下に座れと そこではなきゃ修行ではありませんと
それなら木の下に座ってるみんなも全部修行完了者でしょうに
だから私はまるっきりもう仏教じゃないと言っている人にも言って私は手紙書いたんですよ 10
時半で新宿の南口で会いましょうと
あなたにいっぱい阿羅漢たちを会わせてあげますと
10時半になっちゃう
新宿の南口で阿羅漢たちだらけですよ
だからただお風呂に入らないで臭いだけでね
住むところはないだけで
昼間公園に寝て 夜はもう新宿の南口の駅のところで寝るだけで悟りというわけじゃないんですよ
だからこの性格の問題なんだ
きちんとした頑固な性格を持っているかということなんですね
だからこの心はもう揺らぎない
たとえ贅沢な食べ物を食べても
何も食べ物なくても もう小欲知足の心はそのままね
持っていくと だから贅沢に溺れないことがね
贅沢は最近の人々はいくら持ってきたっても
ありがとうございますとかなんとか言って受け取るかもしれませんだけど
自分の心はもうそんなもんではめげないというところが
お釈迦様がおっしゃっているところなんですね
だからこの目的はこの輪廻を断つことなんですよ
あの 腐りかけてる藁のところに寝ているかないかということじゃないんだ
あなた寝ている 藁敷いて寝てるでしょ
藁腐ってるんで 腐ってないでしょうと
ダメですよと そんな話じゃないんですよ
藁は腐ってなきゃダメですよ
だからそんな形の世界じゃないんですよ
あなたは輪廻を断ちましたかと
不善から心をね 綺麗にしたんですかと
そこら辺はもうすごく目的だからね
だからずっと一生腐ってる藁の中の生活したっても
心が悪のまんまだったら何の意味もないでしょうに
だからこの形ではありません
この心の頑固さ 性格なんですね
めげる性格だったら悟れないと
そこで修行の邪魔っていうのは
イダ
アナンダ タターガタ ロケ ウッパ ジャティ アラハント サмма サムブドド ヴィッジャ チャラナ サンパ
ンノ スガト ロカ ヴィドゥ アヌットロ プルサ サマ サラティ サッターデーマヌッサナム ブドド ガガワ
それでお釈迦様が現れるんだと
こういうこういうここの特色がありますね
それでお釈迦様はヴィヴィッタン セーナ アスナン バジェティ
お釈迦様は人々から離れたところに生活します
アラニャ ルッカ ウラン
森やら木の下やら パッバタン
山 カンダランはわかりません
ギリグワンっていうのは洞窟とかね
スサーナンっていうのは墓地
で ワナパッタンっていうのは森
アッボーカーサンっていうのは空き地
パララプンジャンっていうのはこの藁の捨ててるところですね
タッサタッタールーパカッタッサヴィヘラトアンワーワッテニ
それでまたバラモン人たちやらどんどん出てくるんだと
そこでこのバラモン人たちがサッシャンカたちが来ても
お釈迦様はアナワッテス
全然転落はしません で
ナムッチャティカーマヤティ
ああ これがいいな これが美味しいなとか
あのバラモンたちが持ってくるものについては全然もう使ってはいるんだけど
全然もう欲はない ね ゲーダティ
欲張ることは全くないと
ね アーワッテティバーフリャーエ
贅沢 贅沢に転落することは全くない
お釈迦様は だからお釈迦様も森の中には生活しているんだけど
それで大勢の人々がそちらに来たら
もうすぐそちらでやっぱり贅沢な世界が現れちゃうんですね
いくら物質的な物理的な贅沢な世界が現れたって
お釈迦様の心は全然転落はしないと
あの状態を守っているんだと
タッセワコーパナアヌサトゥサワコタッササットヴィエカンアニウト
ブルー
ハーヤマーナヴィヴィッタンセーナアサナンバジャティアランニャンルッカモーランパッバタンカンダランギタッサタッターウーパカッタッサヴィヒルトアナワットディマン
で それで弟子がどうなるんですかね
そこでお釈迦様が森の中に生活していると
バラモンって祭儀の人々が来てすごい贅沢を持ってきて
そこで大変なことにする
お寺作ったりとか でもお釈迦様は全然それに囚われることなく
もうお布施は使いますけど
全然囚われることなく清らかな心でいると
弟子もいるんでしょうに
弟子たちも師と一緒に森の中に生活を始めたんだけど
このもう人々が入ってくると
ズルズルと心が転落してしまって
贅沢の方へ それで彼には立派な先生がいるにも関わらず
修行ができなくなっちゃうんです
だから先生はいいんだけど
弟子の心がちょっと贅沢に
もうもうなんとなく曲げちゃいますから
傾いちゃうんだから それで修行に邪魔
まだ修行中だから心の汚れあるのは当たり前なんですけど
やっぱりそれでも贅沢にちょっと転落しようかなという気持ちで
もう修行にもう邪魔なんですよと
災いですよと その三つ勉強しなさいと
先生の災い 弟子の災い
それからまあ修行の災いと
その三つの中でブラフマチャリアウパッダというものが
いわゆる先生の災いも大したことはないと
もう弟子の災いも大したことない
でも修行に災いが生まれるんだったら
これ大変な危険だと ドゥッカヴィパーカータローチェヴァカトゥクヴィパーカータローチェアピッチャヴィニパーターヤサンワッタティ
ですから 修行する弟子がもう美味しいものを食べられてよかったなとか
ちょっとニコッと微笑みながら美味しいものを食べちゃっても
真面目に修行するんだったら大丈夫ですよ
今日は寝るときはちょっと敷くため敷物をもらっちゃって
なんか暖かく寝られたなとかね
それでちょっと素直に喜んだっても
そんな大した危険ではないと
それ危険は危険なんですけどね
喜ぶなよと そんなことでということは厳しくあるんだけど
でも修行に邪魔になっちゃうと
例えば瞑想しながら美味しいもの食べちゃったけど
あれ美味しかったなとかってなっちゃうとダメなんですね
もう食べる時はもうまあまあ美味しいんじゃないかなと
それでもう消え去ったり忘れちゃうと
お釈迦様はたち美味しいものであろうと
もう執着で食べてますけど
弟子がやっぱり美味しいなとかね
これとかねと思ったり食べたりすると
その場合は先生たちはこいつはなんか欲しがってる
じゃあこれも食べなさい
自分のものやとかってでもあげる場合ありますよ
君はなんか好きみたいだから
じゃあこれも食べなさい
私の分も で それはちょっとしたね
人間のね ちょっとした弱みだから
そこは本当はあんまり危険ということではないんだけど
瞑想するたって あの食べ物ばっか浮かんで
あーおいしかったな おいしかったなとかね
明日も用意もらうかなとかね
そういうことになると
もう頭が混乱してるんですね
それで修行できないので
それこそ徹底した邪魔だと
この三つの災いの中から修行の災いは一番災いだと
えーと タスマーティヒマンアーナンダミッタヴァターヤサムジャチャラタマサッパッタヴァターヤ
それはどういう意味ですかね
だからアーナンダよ 私のことは友人だと思いなさいって意味なんですよ
敵やと思うなよと まあ死んでしまえと言うんだけど
お釈迦様は 言う時は言うんだけど
でも私は友人やと思いなさいと
敵やと思うなよと どういう風に日本訳はなってます？それゆえアーナンダよ
私に対して友 友誼を持って行動しなさい
敵意を持って行動してはなりませんということで
そこで師弟関係はぴったし決めてますね
お釈迦様っていうのは本当にもうそういうミッタヴァターヤというすごい友人やと
戦友やと 敵だと思うなよと
そこでお釈迦様を友人に
戦友にする方法を次に説明するんですね
イダアーナンダサッサーサーヴァカーナンダンマンデーセディアヌカンパコヒテーシアヌカンパンウパダーヤ
それであの師はあの弟子たちのことを心配して
あの法を説くと イダンヲヒタイイダンヲスカーヤと
これは君たちには役に立ちます
これは君たちの幸福になりますと
タッササーヴァカーナスッスーサンティナソウタンウーダハンティアンニャンチッタンウパッタヴェンティ
こうしなさい こうしなさいと言うんだけど
弟子の連中は全然聞いてくれないと
あっちこっち聞いて心が行ってるんだと
ボッカンマチャサットサーサナワッタンティ
お釈迦様の教えからはみんな脱線する
話聞かない エワンコアナンドサッターランサーワカサッパッタワターエサムダーチャランティノーミッタワターエ
もしお釈迦様は一生懸命心配して喋っているのに
あっち見たりこっち見たり
あまり何でしたっけ？とかね
この前そういう腹が立つことあったんです
せっかく話したのは何？と聞いたんです
その瞬間でもう二度と顔を合わせるなよと言いたくなったんだけどね
だからそういう風な仏教も難しいんですよ
甘えて怠けてね 私にも
私は普通のバカな人間かもしれませんだけど
ブッダの世界背負ってるんだからね
私にもどうすることもできないんですよ
あんたちょっとこれ何とかしてくれって言ったっても
自分が運転しているのはある決まりの乗り物だからね
それは何とかできませんよ
飛行機に乗ったら 私はちょっとあんたパイロットさんもうもう仲がいいんじゃないか
そこら辺ちょっと俺ってこれと言ったっても
それはできませんよ もう決まりだから
もう決まりじゃなくて法則だから
次の飛行場に行くまでもうどうにもならん
まあそれでお釈迦様が指導説法するしているのにも関わらず
あまり聞く耳を持ってないとか
まあそうですか じゃあこのうちやってみますとかね
そういう感じになること自体がお釈迦様を敵に回していることだと
それが偉大なるお釈迦様を自分が敵だ敵だ敵だと思っていることだと
だからあんた方は地獄に落ちるんだ
しょうがないんですよ
カタンチャーナンドサッターランサーワカミッタワターエサムダーチャランティ
お釈迦様に対して優義を持って
本当に素晴らしい友人やと思って生活する方法は何なのかというと
お釈迦様は一生懸命心配して説法するでしょうに
その説法はきちんと聞いてくださいと
あっちこっち心は脱線しないで
じっと集中して聞いてくださいと
聞いたら まああんた方の長い間の幸福になりますよと
それがタンウォーバビセディーガラタンヒタエスカーヤ
ノーウォーアハンアーナンダサターパラッカミッサーミヤタークンバカーローアーマケーアーマカマッテーニッガイヒャニッガイヤハンアーナンダワッカハミ
タワイハパワイヒャパワイヒャ
ヨーサーロッソータッサティーティ
この最後の例えはすごい立派なんですよ
それ日本訳をちょっと見てみましょう
アーナンダ 私に対して勇気を持って行動しなさい
敵意を持って行動して
それは長い間そなたたちの利益のために安楽のためになるはずです
アーナンダよ 私はあたかも
何？陶工？陶工が生の乾いているものに対するように
乾いていないですね  何？乾いていないものに対するように
そなたたちに対して努力することがありません
努力することはありません
どういう意味ですかね
アーナンダよ 私は抑え抑え解きます
アーナンダよ 私は運び運び解きます
真実なるものがとどまるはずです
時間をかけて指導するって意味じゃない？全体からこの通り
今日は アーナンダタッター
パラッカミッサン  努力することがないってのはほっとくってこと？ 違うんですよ
ニッガイニッガイアーナンダワッカ
だからこの陶器って言ったっても
これはすごく乱暴に扱うできますよ
もう焼いたきちんとしたものだったら
生だったらどうしますかね
だから陶器の 何て言いますか
大工さんかな 何さんでしたっけ
陶工がこれ土がすごく生い土でしょ
まだまだ乾いてないでしょうに
だからそれは扱う時はすごく丁寧に扱って
叩いたりして もうへったりして
もう削ったり いろんなことをして
手を加えて丁寧に扱うんですよ
それから焼いて もうきちんと芯のあるものにするんです
だからお釈迦様に叩かれても
もう抑えられても 潰されても
それは陶工と同じ気持ちだと
とにかく立派な作品 最後にも出して見せるんやと
いくらかできた陶器なんか欠け傷あるんだったら
また全部潰しちゃって
またもう一度練ってまたやってみるっていうことをいくらでもあるでしょうに
だからまあ昔はね よく叩くんですよ
生 生 土を 叩く場合はこの叩いて叩いて薄くするんですよ
で なんとかろくろで回してる間もね
やっぱりこうやって叩いて叩いて
丁寧に叩いてね だからかなりもう神経使うお仕事なんですよ
やってることは叩いてることなんですけどね
だからこの生の粘土を扱ってる
あの陶工みたいと同じく
お釈迦様は人間をもうかなり丁寧に扱ってる
乱暴はしませんと だからパラッカマミっていうのはこの
乱暴しないということなんです
だからまだまだ生の陶器だから
その期待をしてないんですよ
だからもう陶器生で売ってもいいんですよ
水くんでくださいということはない
だからちゃんとそこら辺は考えて考えて
調整して調整して 一旦火にかけて焼いて戻ってからもう仕事にはなりますからね
そういう風に このいきなり乱暴に何とかということはしてないんだから
敵ではありませんと ブッダは
だからあの 生の乾いてない粘土を扱うように
もう叩くところを叩いて
運ぶところは運んで ここら辺にもうちょっと粘土持っていこうとかね
ここら辺もちょっと伸ばしておこうとかね
そうやって運ぶところを運んで
押さえるところを押さえてやって
陶器を作るんでしょうに
生の間は だから乱暴はしないんだと
そこで あの 例えばろくろに回してる時でも
大体軽く手を指を入れるだけでしょうに
それちょっとでも間違ったら出てこないんですよ
だからこの手か指か この入れ方っていうのはものすごく優しくて
すごくこの角度を決めて
この強すぎ 強くもなく柔らかくもないという
このこのちょうどいい
これはなかなかできないでしょうに
それで一旦形ができたっても
元の粘土から切ってもらわなくちゃあかんでしょうに
これは素人にいくら頼んだってできないでしょうに
できる人はちゃんとはい
出来上がった じゃあ自分でこの何か糸できるでしょ
あれは 糸はサッと持っていくだけのことなんですけど
見る限り簡単単純です
では誰かにはい これ取ってください
慣れてないとまるっきりできないんだから
ロクロ回してるのとこうやって持ってきて
それからこれ取るだけのことなの
それでコチャンってなっちゃいますからね
ですから その丁寧で すごく気をつけて
この縄の粘土を扱っているような感じで
私はあんた方を管理しているんだと
やがて芯のあるものが出るんでしょうと
っていうことですから
すごいいい例えだと思いますね
ヨーサロソタッサティーって
そこでどうせ粘土の世界ではしっかりできたものをちゃんと何とかに入れて
あれ 何て言いますか 窯に入れて焼いて
しっかりした作品とはできている
出来の悪いものはそのまま処分しちゃう
もう関係ないと ですから
やっぱりみんな百パーセント悟るってことはないんです
やっぱり言うことやってくれない
なんかいい加減ちゃんだったらもうもう作品うまくできてない作品ですから
そのままそのまま追い出しちゃうという
だから陶器の場合もね
やっぱりもう百ぐらい作ったっても
役に立つのは二十とか三十とか
人はすごいプロだったらね
まあ九十個ぐらいもできるかもしれませんだけど
一般の人の場合 百個作っちゃうとね
まあ三十ぐらい せいぜい良い作品のこと
そこから全部もうダメとになりますよ
まあとにかくこの大空空性というものを説明しようとする
お釈迦様はあらゆる方面で話を持っていって
ものすごい綺麗に話が進む
パーフェクトに収束させるんですよ
だから空ってどのように見るべきかと
空とこの涅槃に悟りに関係とかね
ちょっと一つ だからものすごい膨大な経典なんですよ
膨大な内容が入っています
だから何回何回も読み直して読み直してしないとね
まあだから日本語で読んでも
このあの生きてる意味は通らないことは通らないんです
それはまあもう私が威張ってるのか言うわけではなくて
まあそれは経典の在り方で
訳では生きてる意味は通らないんです
訳は正しく間違ってるわけじゃないんですけどね
でも釈言の話みたいなもので
何やとわからなくなっちゃうんですね
お香の仏法僧の三宝に礼拝して
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナーの修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱を得られますように
ではどうもありがとうございました
どうもありがとうございました